Brad and Angelina are taking a pause in
their divorce case so are they calling
off and getting back together
sorry Brangelina fans if you were hoping
to see a reconciliation for these a
listers we have some bad news for you a
source close to the situation tells UT
there isn't one in the works
so why the pause in the divorce
proceedings our source tells us it's for
the sake of the kids we are a family and
we will always be a family and we will
get through this time and and hopefully
be a stronger family alright Brad and
Angie are simply putting co-parenting
their six kids first
Brad hinted he and Angie would take
things slow when he sat down with GQ
style back in May he said quote you
spend a year just focused on building a
case to prove your point and why you're
right and why they're wrong and it's
just an investment in vitriolic hatred I
just refused and fortunately my partner
in this agrees it's just very very
jarring for the kids to suddenly have
their family ripped apart and in her
Vanity Fair tell-all from last month
Angelina admitted nearly eleven months
after she filed for divorce the family
is quote just coming up for air we're
told there's no animosity between Brad
and Angelina in fact she and the six
kids now live near Brad in this 25
million dollar mansion
[Music]